اني اسمي ثريا حسني
وكنت ديما مغرومه معناتها بالزيت الزيتون
ونشوف هلا هو هذا الذهب نتاعنا في تونس
وكيفاش النجمه نجيبوا الافكار جدد ولانه
باش نقدمو القطاع هذايا ونوريه للعالم
الكل
[موسيقى]
ابليكيشن
ونعملوا تتبيع
الزيت الزيتون القهوه الكاكاو
[موسيقى]
صعوبه برشا واحد يبدا من
بلد كيما تونس احنا عنا برشا حاجات نجمهم
العالم اما العالم ما يعرفنيش
نبدو ونحبوا عنا برشا احلام اما منلقاوش
ديما البيبين محلولين عندي برشا مشاريع
واحلام
انه نحب
القطاع الفلاحي يولي
حاجه نجم نقدموها في البلدان نتاعنا خاطر
عنا برشا بلدان وعنا
في تونس في الجزائر في ليبيا في مصر في
السعوديه فما هذيا قطاعي تنجم يتكبر برشا
اما نحب نحبه ويقعد
سستين نحبه نخموا في في
وكيفاش النجم نقدموه بالتكنولوجيا
والتقاليد
القطاع نتاعنا يكبر